Rounding out the list of incredible things...
...and places in Norway is the Midnight Sun.
The strangest thing was watching the sun go down...
...and having it just hover right above the horizon.
It would set at about midnight,...
...just kind of hang there,...
...and then it would start to rise at 1:00 AM.
The Midnight Sun is a natural phenomenon...
...that occurs in the summer months in places north of the Arctic Circle.
But actually, the Midnight Sun can occur almost 50 miles away from the circle...
...but not quite as high.
Your body clock is so thrown out of whack...
...because, imagine, you are as tired as can be but it is light out.
It's the strangest, just most bizarre thing.
It's very hard to sleep in Norway.
It is right now 12:30 in the morning.
It's June the 11th so it's almost the first day of summer,...
...which is the longest day of the year.
I haven't been sleeping the past two days just because it doesn't get dark.
It's always light out.
I mean, look at this.
The sun just dips down low enough below the horizon,...
...where it's like a sunset for two hours straight,...
...and then it pops right back up at about 2:00, maybe 1:45.
Real strange but kind of cool.